well there we have it
after months of deceit and deception
the pathetic spectacle of a man who's
run out of road
[Music]
his defense his defense that he didn't
realize he was at a party
[Laughter]
it is so ridiculous
that it's actually offensive to the
british public
he's finally been forced to admit what
everyone knew that when the whole
country was locked down he was hosting
boozy parties in downing street
is he now going to do the decent thing
and resign
well uh mr speaker
it is
hancock
i think somebody will be going for an
early cup of tea as well can i just say
the questions being asked i want to know
the answer your constituents want to
know the app
i don't need any extra help either so
please
prime minister
yeah
well mr speaker i i i i appreciate the
uh the the point that he's making about
the the event that i
i attended uh i i want to i want to
repeat that uh i thought it was a work
event and and mr speaker
uh i i i regret i regret very much i
regret very much that we did not do
things differently uh that evening and
mr speaker as i've said and i take
responsibility and i apologize uh mr
speaker
but as for as for his uh his political
point i don't think that he should uh
preempt the outcome of the inquiry
uh he will have he will have a further
opportunity mr speaker i hope uh to
question me as soon as possible
[Music]
well that apology was pretty worthless
wasn't it
let me tell him why this matters
yesterday in this chamber honourable
members told heart-wrenching stories
about the sacrifices people across the
country were making
this house
and the whole country were moved by the
honourable member for trust strangford
as he talked about his mother-in-law
dying alone
he was following the rules
whilst the prime minister was parting in
downing street
is the prime minister really so
contemptuous of the british public that
he thinks he could just ride this out
[Applause]
mr speaker i i heard
the testimony of the honourable member
opposite and i and i and i i share i
echo his uh his sentiments it was it was
deeply moving nobody who heard that uh
could fail uh to have been moved and i
know that people up and down the country
i made huge sacrifices throughout this
pandemic uh mr speaker and i understand
the anger the rage that they feel the
thought that uh
that people in dining street were not
following those rules i i regret
i regret the way uh the event i have
described uh was handled i bitterly uh
regret it and wish that we could have
done things differently and i have uh
and will continue to apologize for what
we did but mr speaker he must wait uh
for the inquiry which will report as
soon as possible
mr speaker when the prime minister's
former health sector broke the rules
he resigned
and the prime minister said he was right
to do so
when the prime minister spokesperson
laughed about the rules being broken she
resigned
and the prime minister accepted that
resignation
why does the prime minister still think
that the rules don't apply to him
[Applause]
mr speaker that's not what i've said and
i i understand i understand the point
that he uh that he makes uh i as i've
said mr speaker i uh regret the way
things happened on the evening in
question
and i apologize but if i may say to him
i do think it would be better if he
waited until the full conclusion of the
inquiry until the full facts are brought
before this house mr speaker and he will
then have an opportunity to put his
points again
[Music]
this just isn't working prime minister
no everyone could see what happened
it started with reports of boozy parties
in downing street during lockdown
the prime minister pretended that he had
been assured there were no parties
how that fits with this defense out i do
not know
exactly then the video landed
blowing the prime minister's first
defense out of the water
so then he pretended he pretended he was
sickened and furious
about the parties
now it turns out he was at the parties
all along
can't the prime minister see why the
british public think he's lying through
his teeth
[Applause]
prime minister
it was what the public think not one
member is saying it's
and i certainly don't need any help from
around here if somebody wants to help me
they can help someone else prime
minister
mr speaker it's up to the right
honourable gentleman to choose how he uh
conducts himself in this
place
he's wrong
he is
he's wrong
[Applause]
i say to him i say to him that he is
wrong
uh he is wrong in what he said in
in in
he said what he is wrong in in
what he said is wrong in several key
respects but mr speaker that does not
detract from the uh the basic point that
i want to make today which is which is
that i i accept that we should have done
things differently on that evening i as
i as i've said to the house
i believe
that the events in question were within
the guidance and were within the rules
and that was certainly the assumption on
which i operated but can i say to to him
mr speaker that he should wait he should
wait uh you know before he jumps to
conclusions mr speaker a lawyer should
respect the the the inquiry
i i hope that he will wait until the
facts are established and brought to
this house
here's starbucks
mr speaker so we've got the prime
minister attending downing street
parties a clear breach of the rules
we've got the prime minister putting
forward a series of ridiculous denials
which he knows are untrue
a clear breach of the ministerial code
that code says ministers who knowingly
mislead parliament will be expected to
offer their resignation
the party's over prime minister
the only question is will the british
public kick him out will his party kick
him out or will he do the decent thing
and resign
mr speaker i i i just want to repeat
that i think that the uh right honorable
gentleman i and i i know that it is his
objective and he's paid to try to remove
me from office mr speaker and i i
appreciate that and i accept that but
may i humbly suggest to him uh that he
should he should wait until the inquiry
has concluded uh he should study it uh
for himself and i will certainly respond
as appropriate and i hope that he does
but in the meantime uh yes mr speaker i
certainly wish uh that things had
happened differently on the evening of
may the 20th mr speaker and i apologize
for all the misjudgments uh that have
been made for which i take mr speaker
full responsibility pierced armor
the prime minister's a man without shame
the public want answers to their
questions
hannah brady's father sean was just 55
when he lost his life to covid he was a
fit and healthy key worker
i spoke to hannah last night prime
minister
her father died
just days before the drinks trolley was
being wheeled through downing street
and last year
hannah met the prime minister
in the downing street garden
she looked at the prime minister in the
eye and told him of her loss the prime
minister told hammer he'd done
everything he could to protect her dad
looking back what hannah told me last
night was this she realizes
that the prime minister had parted
in that same garden the very day
her dead her dad's death certificate was
signed
what hannah wants to know is this
does the prime minister understand why
it makes her feel sick
to think about the way that he's behaved
mr speaker i sympathize
deeply with uh with hannah with people
who have suffered up and down this
country during the pandemic and i repeat
that i wish things had been done
differently on that evening mr speaker
and i i repeat my apology for all the
misjudgments that may have been made
that were made on my watch
in number 10 and across a government but
i want to to reassure the people of this
country including hannah and and her
family uh that mr speaker we have been
working to do everything we can to
protect her and her family and it is
thanks to the efforts of this government
uh that we have the most tested
population in europe with 1.25 million
tests being conducted every day
we've been working to ensure that this
population our country has the most
antivirals of any country in in europe
and mr speaker it's because of the
efforts of the government of officials
of staff up and down whitehall that
we've driven the fastest vaccine rollout
in
europe uh one of the fastest in the
world and that is the reason mr speaker
that we now have one of the most open
economies if not the most open economy
in europe uh and one of the fastest
growing economy mr speaker in the g7 and
mr speaker whatever the mistakes that
have been made on my watch for which i i
apologize and which i fully acknowledge
that is the work mr speaker that has
been going on in number 10 dining street
[Applause]